senator Kamala Harris announced this
morning she is entering the 2020
presidential race she released an
official campaign video detailing her
plans
the California Democrat invited
supporters to join her at a kickoff
rally in her hometown of Oakland next
Sunday
Edie keep is on Capitol Hill good
morning and another woman joining the
race yet another of Nora that's right
good morning Harris is bypassing the
exploratory phase and jumping right in
becoming an official candidate today the
54 year old senator was elected to the
Senate in 2016 and is the former
attorney general of California and
District Attorney of San Francisco in
that role she fought to legalize
same-sex marriage Harris made headlines
during Supreme Court justice Brett
Kavanaugh s confirmation hearing for
questions about the ongoing Russia
investigation and abortion rights and
she's probably best known up here on
Capitol Hill for that type of tough
questioning of witnesses as a member of
the judiciary and intelligence
committees she's now the third female
senator to jump into the presidential
race joining Elizabeth Warren of
Massachusetts and Kirsten Gillibrand of
New York and on this Martin Luther King
jr. Day she is the first black candidate
to enter the 2020 democratic race but
Harris is also Indian American on her
mother's side she's the first Indian
American elected to the Senate and her
decision to join the race just proves
again that the Democratic field in 2020
is going to be unlike any we've ever
seen it sure is that it's quite crowded
indeed thanks ad